what is it where is it it's here
somewhere just because you can't see
something doesn't mean it isn't
important ask your doctor and the
European Parliament conference of
presidents is important this is the only
point where in our institution with 754
members from 27 to 28 member states you
can focus a little bit and concentrate a
little bit on real consistent
decision-making which is very very
difficult in the plenary in the
committee's the conference of presidents
brings together the leaders of the
political groups the President of the
European Parliament presides over the
meetings normally held twice a month in
Brussels and Strasbourg he's joined by
the Parliament secretary-general and by
the leaders of all the political groups
or their substitutes the group of
non-attached members have one seat there
too but no voting rights because a
delicate cannot speak for all their
colleagues so what do they do la
confianza presidency Logan ki duwa
organizado travail de Panama prepare a
risotto Jojo example selkie das aranea
sheree porsha no regard only Dos Equis
son play polymetal audio-visual estas Bo
Tong said noggin la preparación vitamin
C treason photo epicenter Nagano CCDC de
deux chevaux de discutir indifferent
Commission it's a useful body of all the
political group chairman to to get
together it sets the political agenda
for the for the plenary and sets the
political priorities and gives the
president his instructions etc about
what he could say to European councils
etc yes so it's a very important
political coordinating body the
conference of presidents organizes the
work of the European Parliament it's
consulted on everything concerning
legislative planning and relations with
other EU bodies and institutions it's
also responsible for matters relating
good relations with non-eu countries
institutions and
organizations it's the conference of
presidents that considers the European
Parliament's calendars of meetings and
sets its agendas it's responsible for
the composition and powers of committees
committees of inquiry standing
delegations and other bodies it also
takes the final decision on who will win
the annual sakharov prize for freedom of
thought so it matters we are the leaders
of the political groups and without
assets not possible to decide anything
in this famous conference of presidents
also called the cop we are trying today
for example to get organized for the
plenary session and this sounds very
easy but it's sometimes very difficult
when there is disagreement the votes of
delegates are weighted according to the
size of the groups they represent la
program papec a trap or sunday decision
some pre-press kalinin imitate danke
sehr a discussion on track oleg kisa
preparado on evo de cerca de janeiro a a
pair seria de description Trey politic a
la fosse come down to diba Democratic
idea vote on flickr politic kiseop hasta
el agua don't honk account shows a
dual-level adoro nose amor como estas
pasando voir la confianza president
Mason to see pawar a majority dokie
funny go see the conference of President
sometimes host important visitors such
as council president herman van rompuy
or German Chancellor Angela Merkel it's
a bottle with a major role to play from
organization point of view the
conference of presidents is one of the
most important bodies of European
Parliament so you can't see it you can't
hear it but just like for instance your
pancreas or your spleen it fulfills a
vital function you miss it if it wasn't
there